alright the reddit discussion forum
continues to grow there is a ton of show
content now coming from the reddit
discussion forum from you people in the
audience you can check it out at david
pakman.com slash reddit as i mentioned
we had uh nearly three times the prior
number of page views on the reddit
discussion forum in November November
bested the prior single month record for
page views on the red discussion forum
by nearly 3x we also have Oh around 2100
david pakman show viewers and listeners
on the reddit discussion forum let's
look at some of the interesting
discussions that have started at david
pakman.com slash reddit there's one
point post but called current david and
it's an entire discussion about the ways
in which i've changed my approach to the
show after the election and some people
saying david has gone way left after the
election of Donald Trump others saying
well no David just now recognizes the
importance of progressive activism
others saying David's gone completely
off the deep end which is never too far
behind when you're having any discussion
of the david packard show very
interesting conversation about what i've
been doing politically since november
eighth another discussion from our
reddit discussion forum about this
progressive action coordinator and
people putting up a lot of different
ideas about how the progressive
engagement coordinator uh that is one of
the goals of the current indiegogo
campaign at david pakman.com slash
donate could actually be organized what
the tasks would be and how it would be
most effective very interesting i'm
looking at it closely because i think
there's really good ideas there another
discussion from our reddit discussion
forum examining the most compelling
pizzagate evidence and it is a very
extensive post about the so-called
evidence involved in the pizza gate
conspiracy theory i keep going back and
forth about whether we are going to do
an investigation or a larger analysis
into pizzagate or whether we are going
to leave it be i know that if you look
at our reddit discussion forum there's a
lot of people who want a major major
analysis another discussion from reddit
David don't cover pizza gate and this is
another uh sentiment that is on the
reddit discussion forum which is there's
the people who say you've gotta cover
pizza gate David and then there are
people who say David you're attracting
conspiracy nuts to the David Pakman show
subreddit by even mentioning it please
don't talk about it anymore and lastly
from the reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash reddit quick note
regarding the new phone call in system
yes we we are aware that there are still
some glitches to work out this was a
very extensive post from Brody Mulligan
who wrote that it's great that we now
have a cue to put callers on hold but
that it's hard to tell when I've
actually put a particular caller on this
is because you used to hear hold music
until I put you on but now you hear
other callers talking to me until I put
you on it's a work in progress Pat what
what I know is that the call system we
have today is orders of magnitude better
than the one we had two months ago yes
much better to pick from a list of
people than having them call and then
their call may drop before we actually
get to them it now there's no more busy
signal which i think is also one of the
best things about the new callin system
so yes it is still a work in progress
there will be some improvements made
over the weekend please subscribe to the
reddit discussion forum a lot of great
conversation there david pakman.com
slash read it